hey guys my name is jeff mcdonald it is
the 26th of june today and you are tuned
in to gain spot news my first story of
the day has the phrase Rock simulator in
it so let's grit our teeth and find out
if rolling also factors into the
equation weather alert it does the fact
that a rock simulator has come to steam
greenlight might be one of the dumbest
things to happen for ages but
miraculously at the type of this
recording the pictures skyrocketed to
the ninth most popular title on the
service responsible for catering to the
overlooked cavernous neisha proc
simulations is strange Panther games
who've called the title a rock
enthusiast stream apparently will be
able to watch beautiful rocks in any
location in the world for some reason
derek and games like goat simulator have
made themselves a hard act to follow in
the simulation genre or as my kids you
reckons do you think it's an igneous
idea let me know next up details for GTA
online's long-awaited high smooth have
been unveiled and here's what you need
to know youtube user damas light posted
videos about the missions whose details
were pulled from a stray file in GTA
online official Xbox Magazine has
expanded on the mood details which
include a prison van rescue where
criminals are free a gang member from an
NPC driven van a road where one must
pick up and drop off a hooker within a
time limit a funeral mode where gang
members have to escort a hearse through
a town which rival gang members tried to
destroy and a fairly straightforward
bank heist among others let me know if
any of these takes your fancy it seems
that silly tag lines do not begin and
end with Sony's where the greatest place
since Microsoft have just recently
launched the new xbox one tagline it's
more fun on Xbox one Microsoft's tagline
was revealed in a video that claims with
the best exclusives spectacular new
franchises and the best multiplayer
community it's more fun on xbox one I
really want to stop saying that now in
all fairness Microsoft is saying that
with the release of sunset overdrive
halo the master chief collection and a
bunch of other games they're expecting a
good year for
who splurged on their system the company
have also posted a list of all the
exclusive and non-exclusive games coming
to Xbox one this year which you can
check out on gamespot I'd also recommend
watching their game heavy montage video
which chances are you're viewing this
very second to get a good overview of
what's on the way retailer games stopped
weighed in on the recent reception for
the system saying customer demand for
the Xbox one video game console
continues to remain high and we're
thrilled with the accelerated pace of
consumer adoption we're experiencing let
me know whether you reckon the xbox one
video game console has the best
exclusive and best multiplayer community
or not so much those are all the things
that I wanted to tell you about today
but in just 24 hours I will be back with
some words on my five favorite gay me
stories of the whole week so be sure to
join me then